Pinocchio is a software
system for automatic animation
of 3D characters.
Given a 3D character mesh and
a generic skeletal motion,
Pinocchio adapts the
skeleton to the character
and applies the
motion to the shape.
The result is an
animated character.
As we developed
Pinocchio, we used
about 70 different
characters for testing.
After Pinocchio
had been completed,
we tested it on 16
biped characters
that we did not see or
use during development.
Here, all 16 of our test
characters are shown.
A single biped skeleton was
used to animate all of them,
demonstrating the
generality of our approach.
Three of these characters
required a single manual hint
to produce a good motion.
On a mid-range PC,
Pinocchio typically
takes under a minute
to animate a character.
Pinocchio can produce
plausible animations,
even in some unexpected cases.
It can also work with
non-biped skeletons.
We were unable to obtain a
centaur for motion capture.
This motion is the
capture of a human hopping
applied to a centaur skeleton.
Pinocchio works as follows.
It packs spheres
into the character
and constructs a graph
on their centers.
It then finds an embedding
of the given skeleton
into this graph that minimizes
a measure of distortion.
It uses continuous
optimization to refine
the positions of the skeleton
joints within the character.
It solves the diffusion
equilibrium equation
on the character surface
to compute the bone weights
for skeleton
subspace deformation.
Once the character
is rigged, Pinocchio
uses online motion retargeting
to eliminate foot skate.
Pinocchio requires
that the character
be given in roughly
the same orientation
and pose as the skeleton.
This is the result if the
character's orientation
is flipped vertically.
Pinocchio has no
capability to differentiate
between materials.
This leads to unrealistic,
rubbery motion of a knight's
armor and a woman's dress.
In our blind validation
test, Pinocchio correctly
embedded the skeleton into
13 of our 16 test models.
Pinocchio incorrectly
embedded the skeleton
into these three
test characters.
However, a manual hint for
the placement of one joint
was sufficient to correct
the problem for each of them.
The asymmetry in the
middle character's skeleton
is due to the asymmetry
in the character.
The following animations
demonstrate a results
on the more interesting of
our test characters close up.
Pinocchio is best suited for
children and amateur animators.
It generates pleasing animations
automatically in almost all
of our tests with
unfamiliar 3D shapes.